A touching moment.
We love this story,
capturing the hearts of so many.
Take a look.
This is the image that has gone
It shows a Delta Airlines
flight attendant going above
and beyond
to comfort a passenger
who is apparently afraid to fly.
You see him there
holding her hand as she as
he sits on the aisle
right next to her seat.
That gentleman joins us now.
Floyd Shannon, you are wonderful
And you could never fly
to the Super Bowl with you.
And I know you'll take good care
Good morning.
So tell me, how are you doing?
We're better that you're here.
Better that you're here.
Can you tell us take us to that
So to briefly run you through it
real quick.
She came on board the plane,
and when she came onto the plane
she was a little nervous.
And before we even took off,
she started sweating real bad.
And I was you know,
once we got to the elevation
of two times,
I went ahead and said and got up
And as
And that's my former coworker,
my my partner and I.
Can you do the briefing
while I go hand to her?
And I sat down and I said, are y
She said, I don't want this.
I'm embarrassed.
I say, it's no need to be embarr
I'm here.
I explained everything to her.
From what?
From what
noise for what wave
turbulence we had going on.
I did what I had in this plane t
to reassure her
that safety is the key that we h
And then
we want you to have a wow experi
with us.
You said a wild experience
while. While.
Wow, wow.
Wow. Oh, Dove. You okay? Okay.
I just want to make sure. Yes.
Look, there's
nothing with the wild experience
But listen, I got to ask you,
is it true
that you've only been
a flight attendant for three mon
Yes, it is.
It's very much true
that I've only been a flight is
and I graduated in October.
The 26 class of 2022 20 a yeah.
And yes.
And I've been
trying to soar to the highest mo
that I can reach.
I mean, I'm here.
I'm here to serve.
I'm here to give my love to ever
I love to share the love.
We're going to have to find out,
just to fly Just good luck.
Take a trip with him.
Just we want to see
if we let them in on our story
on this interview, on the plane
Yes, our secrets of our secret i
I'm very scared to fly.
People who know me well know tha
And I have had moments
in tears on planes.
And it's been a struggle for me,
and I've worked through it.
But it's folks like you that rea
But Don just told me in the brea
he gets to the top of this story
because obviously
this is the image that has gone
viral on Delta Airlines
flight gets a little bit
I don't like it for the passenge
who we have to be afraid to fly.
And I'll see you there
holding her hand as she come
on, let's go. She sits on me.
I don't right next to her.
See that gentleman? It's time to
What would you do, Shannon?
You are
so the first thing I would do,
win the Super Bowl with you.
I tell you to take care
where we want to fly. Warning.
Good morning.
I will give you.
So tell me
tell me
where you're going with when you
Take us to that moment,
friends, Molly and everybody hav
Well, I want you to do it real q
She came on.
I want to play. You make the bes
When she came onto the plane,
she was a little nervous
when it was close to land
before too close.
You start this way
about you going to be able to be
you know,
once we got to show how many tim
I went ahead
and got up and stuff and I asked
what were you like?
My, my what
where she planned to again,
I said, can you do the briefing?
She was right in New York.
Her no beach here.
I sat down and I said, I got you
she said,
I don't want you to be a bad
deserve a raise.
I don't do anything to raise you
What I did back in the sea.
Oh, yeah.
One of your checked with Delta
been like I just went ahead.
And this is plain to to reassure
that the safety and security
that will
and we want you to head of
publication experience. Right.
That's the only part
you said about wild experience
which is my boss.
Why so
while I've been talking to forme
also, you know.
Okay, okay.
I just want to say they do prais
but just not out of the wild
experience as well.
Listen, this is something
I'm grateful I've been
I'm just waiting 3 million
to make sure that we get.
Yes, it is
is very much true that we will.
Thank you.
It was this week's class of 2022
if you
will give it to your person
so that where you are
and I've been trying to sort of
make you better make your day.
I mean, I'm here today.
I'm here to see you in this year
to give a thank you, everybody.